en côte d'or c'est le treizième ruban
tricolore que l'on couple pour inaugurer
un parc éolien
celui ci comprend neuf machines sur les
communes de sacs nez et chazeuil et du
point de vue du délai entre la naissance
du projet et la coupure de ruban
il est tout à fait dans la norme en 2008
c'est le nerf est venu nous proposer une
implantation et le conseil a été tout de
suite favorable parce qu'on était dans
l' dans la vague des énergies nouvelles
et puis des nouvelles ressources pour
les communes parce que font parler
également il y avait quand même à la clé
des ressources pour la commune elle nous
fait 25 28 28 1028 de 30000 ces voix là
et pour moi c'est je double mon budget
d'investissement dès le lancement de la
politique de transition énergétique et
alors qu'elle est loin d'être la plus
ventée de france l'ancienne région
bourgogne s'était montré très
volontariste en la matière entre 2009 et
aujourd'hui 30 parc éolien soit 3 111
éoliennes ont été installées dans les
quatre départements essentiellement
comme on le voit ici dans l'yonne et la
côte d'or et dans l'avenir ce sont
encore ces deux départements qui
concentrent la majorité des parcs d'ores
et déjà autorisé mais dont la
construction n'a pas encore débuté
la saône-et-loire fait donc figure
d'exception son premier parc éolien
celui de la chapelle au mans près de
gueugnon a été installé voici quelques
semaines la nouvelle région bourgogne
franche comté maintient le même cap
aidé en cela par la mise en place de
l'autorisation unique délivré par les
préfets qui remplace le permis de
construire et l'autorisation d'exploiter
on constate désormais une prolifération
des projets pour lesquels les opérateurs
démarche directement les municipalités
une situation quelque peu désordonné qui
suscite également ici et là de
nombreuses oppositions